- Quentin Tarantino and Miramax
have reached a settlement over the lawsuit
regarding Tarantino's attempt to make NFTs
from the movie "Pulp Fiction"
to which Miramax owns a lot of the rights.
If you don't recall,
Miramax claimed that Tarantino
was infringing Miramax's copyrights
over the movie "Pulp Fiction"
when he planned to create
NFTs based on certain portions
of the script to the movie itself.
It's a shame that we'll
probably never learn
the actual outcome of this suit.
There were arguments on both sides.
Miramax owned the right
to the movie itself,
but Tarantino probably had a good argument
that he owned the rights to
his handwritten screenplays.
Where an NFT falls on
that spectrum, who knows,
but it would be interesting
to have actual case law
on that suit.
And while we won't know who
won or lost this lawsuit,
we do know that there
is a true loser here.
It's the person that bought
Tarantino's first NFT
for $1.1 million.